hello if you have found the ideas i
discussed
interesting and useful perhaps you might
consider purchasing my recently released
book beyond order 12 more rules for life
available from penguin random house in
print
or audio format you could use the links
we provide below or
buy through amazon or at your local
bookstore
this new book beyond order provides what
i hope is a productive and
interesting walk through ideas that are
both philosophically and
sometimes spiritually meaningful as well
as being
immediately implementable and practical
beyond order can be read and understood
on its own
but also builds on the concepts that i
developed in my previous books
12 rules for life and before that
maps of meaning thanks for listening
and enjoy the podcast
[Music]
i'm pleased today to be able to talk to
mr randall wallace he's an american
novelist
screenwriter director producer
and songwriter who came to exceptional
prominence
above his normal prominence let's say by
writing the screenplay
for the historical drama film braveheart
in 1995.
his work on that film earned him a
nomination for the academy award for
best original screenplay
and a writer's guild of america award in
the same category
he has since directed films such as the
man in the iron mask in 1998 we were
soldiers 2002
secretariat 2010 which i just watched
with my wife last night
and heaven is for real 2014. he's also
written
seven novels including the new york
times bestseller
pearl harbor and has founded hollywood
for habitat for humanity and one of the
things i'd like to point out to everyone
who's watching or listening to begin
with is
it's really easy to list off uh um
achievements in a in a row novelist
screenwriter director producer
songwriter
but each what's quite remarkable and
worthy of note is that each of those
is very difficult and unlikely so it's
it's very hard to be a novelist you have
to be able to write
well and then you have to be fortunate
and you have to have the right
connections and you have to time the
market properly
and then to repeat that seven times is
is
is quite a spectacular and unlikely feat
but then to combine that with success as
a screenwriter
which is perhaps if anything even more
difficult than
writing a novel that's successful
because so many people have
to participate in moving an idea from
its initial inception
through the screenwriting process to to
full production
as a movie and then release it's a
unbelievably complicated and unlikely
affair director
that's impossible producer and
songwriter as well
and so the conjunction of all those
things the conjunction of seven rare
events is an extraordinarily rare event
and
one of the things that really made me
interested in talking
talking to mr wallace today is
i'm very curious about how he managed
that what
what his life how his life has been set
up so that that became possible
so so welcome and thank you very much
for agreeing to talk with me
oh thank you jordan i'm i'm absolutely
thrilled to be with you
thank you let me start by asking you
what what you're working on now
everyone's locked down with coved and
what what
what's your what are your plans for now
in the future
um about two years ago uh because i'm a
workaholic
uh the the the ism in my family is
workaholism
and and i i i have that burden it it
produces a lot of
help and advantage sometimes but it's
also
a burden and about two years ago i
decided to take a sabbatical the first
one in my life
and go to rome for five weeks
i wanted to see what it was like to to
be in a place long enough i'd
i've lived in paris for a while but
working on a film which is
16 hour days for months on end and
i've lived in a couple of different
visited a number of foreign countries
but
i wanted to be in a place with some room
with some time to to reflect
and get away and i thought rome would be
perfect and
we went to rome and uh i have three sons
and
at one time or another all three were
there but
we were sitting together on the piazza
nirvana
and um looking at us at a fountain
and um and i said to one of my sons
wouldn't it be cool if the pope could
escape through some of the secret
tunnels that we know were in the vatican
and
and get out and walk around rome as a
normal citizen and
and and one of my other sons said yeah
and maybe kick
ass
and then my other son said you mean the
pope is
batman and i went wait a second
and uh and suddenly an idea was born
and uh out of a kind of a fun exchange
i had friends who were members of opus
dei the
the ultra orthodox catholic organization
and
and they they took us through the
vatican and introduced us to the swiss
guards
and i began to think about
how profound an experience it is that
a man would be would be deemed
by his church to be the the holy father
the representative of god on earth
what kind of crushing weight would that
be
what kind of humility would it require
and and a story began to spin its way
into into my life i have a friend
who's a devout catholic and
he he won't take communion because
he can't make perfect contrition i'm not
a catholic by the way i grew up a
baptist
but he can't um he can't fulfill the
requirements
to take communion because he can't
honestly say
he's gonna refuse to stop
living in sin with the woman he's with
who
he has a child with so he's cut off
from communion and
no matter how much i say to him about
the protestant view
of none of us deserve god's love
we're we're saved only by grace
um it it doesn't it doesn't penetrate
his
his sense of obligation and requirement
and and insufficiency
to take communion and i began to think
about
what if you had a pope who was
absolutely committed
to the the reformation of the church
but he he believed that maybe god was
not going to bless his efforts
unless he became a better man and to
become a better man
he had to own his own sins and
and his deepest sin his greatest guilt
pertains to a young woman who was the
child
of one of the swiss guards who
who tried to protect the popes when
john paul the the second was shot four
times in the stomach
in vatican square other popes have died
under mysterious circumstances
and the idea that these two people come
together
on the night when assassins stormed the
vatican to kill the pope
and they have to try to escape through
the bowels of the vatican
while they're confronting their darkest
secrets and their darkest fears and
faith
that just sounded like the kind of movie
i want to do
and for the first time in my career i
felt
comfortable in saying to people who are
who are who have the financial means to
invest in movies
that i was willing to let them invest as
one of my sons said i could never let
friends invest in movies because it
would destroy me the sense of
responsibility to
to get their money back to them but in
this i had every confidence that this
was
the kind of movie the audience
throughout the world really wants to see
the kind of theme that pertains to
everyone
uh that it would be it would be the the
classic thing we want a hit movie that
really meant
something uh and that's the movie i'm
preparing now
um planning to shoot in rome in
september
uh have an incredible team assembled um
still assembling other people to do it
but but that's that's what's right in my
sights right now
well in a thousand years that isn't a
plot that i would have guessed
[Laughter]
well jordan here's another thing that
that pertains and it's
another of the reasons i'm i'm so
enriched by by your experience by your
journey which
i feel is is just starting
and it's that when you start to direct
there's the the metaphor for me is like
you're crawling into a pipe
and that pipe is 18 months long and
you're going to crawl
through sludge and sometimes even sewage
and there's no turning around
and it's it's all on your shoulders and
you have to keep going
and to stay connected with what i need
to stay connected with to survive
which begins with my family it's
extremely difficult
the the you're in a war
you're in you're in a battle and i've
done a number of movies about fighting
about
men who lead other other men in battle
and it's consuming it's all-consuming
general moore the man that we were
soldiers was about
mel gibson portrayed him he he led the
air
cavalry in the largest battle in vietnam
and he loved his family profoundly but
from the moment he
left fort benning georgia to go to
vietnam till the day he returned more
than a year later he never wrote a
single letter except
to one daughter he wrote he wrote her a
letter back because
she had written him but other than that
he never called his wife
and he loved his wife with ev every
fiber of his being
but he felt he had to he had to keep
every second
focused on how he kept his men alive and
in that sense of how
responsibility can can crush us
is is profound for me
well i've suggested to people
quite constantly and and generally it's
been a suggestion that
people take to heart that the sustaining
meaning
in life is to be found through the
adoption of responsibility but
that is the flip side of it is that
there's always the possibility that you
pile on too much and that you don't
manage to move forward under the load
and that's a danger and
i've seen people who are talented fall
prey to that
talented and hardworking fall prey to
that
and it is definitely a great advantage
to be surrounded by people that love you
and to have a family and all of that so
that you can take some comfort when you
have the
opportunity to do that so that that
screenplay that you're describing that's
going to be you said that'll start
filming in the fall
assuming that we defeat kovid and all of
that
yes and
so what what drew you to the idea
in some sense of putting the pope in an
what sounds like an action movie i mean
i have a friend who writes action
uh novels and he's quite interested in
using
all of the elements
plot development in particular but also
character development that are part of
mass entertainment in say in the
thriller genre
which is very close to the superhero
genre i suppose to investigate
thoughtful matters in depth to marry
what's entertaining and gripping which
always has
an archetypal element otherwise it
wouldn't be entertaining and gripping
to to something that's serious and
i suppose and so it sounds like there's
something like that well i could see
that thread running through all of your
work
um that the marriage of mass attraction
which is certainly
necessary for the success of a movie but
also the exploration of deeper themes
and ethical themes
yes and i i feel that one without the
other
is pale um
an abstract discussion of values
uh is interesting to me intellectually
but i want to know how it's defined in
action
um and an action movie
uh in which no one learns anything and
no one's
required to to grow and sacrifice
is empty i i've been asked why i make
war movies and i always say i don't i
make love stories
i want to know what you love enough to
sacrifice your life
for if necessary um
it's funny jordan in high school
of all the things you know when when the
seniors
in at least in america i assume in other
places but
they're voted different superlatives and
i was
voted most responsible and i found that
the the least sexy uh title you could
possibly have i i
once said to a woman i was dating that
that in high school i was voted most
responsible and she laughed and said
i was voted best legs
and i thought well maybe that's the way
it works the most responsible guy is
supposed to get the
the girl with the best legs but um
but for me it's like um
well i'm sorry this is sort of scattered
but um whenever i'm listening to you
i'll find unexpected treasures
um you'll say something in your in your
lectures
that will cause me to to
see some aspect of my life that i hadn't
interpreted fully and one for me was
when i was in high school i was younger
than most of
my classmates and um
and i saw a lot of bullying and i
experienced some
and when i went to college and there'd
be incidents like you know a linebacker
from the football team would get drunk
and
some some
[Music]
sort of scholarly student on the face
and crush its jaw and i decided
i was going to really learn to fight and
i studied karate and i became a karate
teacher and i
won some championships and when i tried
and i was also
in i was a religion major and i went to
seminary and i
put myself through seminary teaching
karate
and that would make people laugh
they'd think it's an anomaly but i'd say
well
when you were talking about nietzsche uh
saying you know you make a moral choice
if you make a choice because you're
afraid to make the other choice it's not
a moral choice
now i didn't know much about nietzsche
when i was in college i
i just thought he was a german thinker
who didn't know how to spell his last
name
what did this guy do it but uh but
it was that way for me i thought if i
walk away from a fight
i want i want to know as much as i could
know
that it's not because i'm being a coward
it's because i'm choosing
to walk away that i'm that i'm capable
of
of hurting someone and if i have to
fight
i want to be capable of doing it and
that to me all ties in with the notion
of
the complexity of of a choice and
and we're we're entertained in a movie
we're captivated i should say more
by by seeing the
the connection between action and
meaning
well meaning grounds out in action right
something isn't meaningful as far as i
can tell unless it has implications for
action
yes and or or the alternative is that it
has implications for perception because
something meaningful can change the way
you look at something
but the consequence of that is that the
framework within which you act is going
to change
and so it grounds out in action and and
i mean i've always been what would you
fascinated i suppose by the
the uh parallelism between nietzsche and
dostoevsky
because they thought along very similar
lines
um and but dostoevsky has the advantage
over nietzsche in some sense because he
can embody his philosophy and characters
and that actually allows him to go into
more depth
i would say than nietzsche which is
really saying something because
nietzsche
went as far down in some ways as anyone
i've ever
had the misfortune or pleasure to have
read
but and and and it's so interesting how
it works and
in in the brothers karamazov um
dostoyevsky pits ivan against
eliot and ivan is handsome and debonair
and he's he's the warrior type that you
just described
um he's very atheistic and he can put up
a pretty good argument
you know he he tortures his brother
who's a monastic novitiate
with uh stories of children locked in
outhouses overnight and freezing to
death
they were punished by their parents
which dostoevsky took from a newspaper
and
said i don't i cannot possibly imagine
how
there could be a god who was omniscient
and
and had all the other classic attributes
of god who could create a universe where
that
was allowed to happen even once and ivan
it can now debate eliot consistently but
eliot's character is such that he wins
the argument he loses all the battles in
some sense but wins the war
and that's something you can really
portray when you clothe your ideas and
characters
or or when the characters are even more
i think to the point is when the
characters are so profound that they're
acting out ideas
that you couldn't yet make explicit no
one that is one of the things that
that narrative does is that it enables
us to
play out ideas that we're not yet
intelligent enough to understand and
sometimes
the gap between the narrative
representation and the explicit
understanding can be thousands and
thousands of years because we're still
unwrapping
well we're certainly still unwrapping
the bible we're we're unwrapping we're
still
unwrapping shakespeare there's more
depth there than we can
than we can understand explicitly and so
anything that uses character has that
tremendous advantage
and then it also there's also this
strange ability that
some people have in spades to
create fictional worlds that are of
unbelievable profundity and power and
i mean the greatest example of that in
the last 30 years in terms of sheer
imaginative powers got to be jk rowling
and
the harry potter series which you know
gripped the imagination of the entire
planet
for for a decade and produced untold
wealth and spread literacy everywhere as
well
she had an un a remarkably creative
imagination and
something quite mysterious and so you're
you're fortunate enough to work at the
marriage of ideas and
and and drama yes and and you know it's
it's really interesting when when you've
spoken about
dostoevsky and and others uh in some of
your lectures i
i'm fascinated by him and all the
russians i studied russian for
four years in college and uh and read
some of these in the original my russian
wasn't
fluent enough for me to really i mean i
had to grind through them but
tolstoy chekhov chekhov who was
a doctor a medical doctor as well as a
writer
so that that congruence of
of a commitment not just in terms of
literature
but that he used his profession
as a doctor to also inform
him as a writer he
famously said
medicine is my is my wife and literature
is my mistress and
when i tire of one i spend time with the
other
um and um i
and pushkin um who would who would write
stories that that were full of thought
but the story itself was bigger than any
thought he could put around it it was
it was more resonant it it carried more
um by the way when i listened to your
your biblical series it caused me to
decide to read through the whole bible
and just start to finish and i grew up
southern baptist so
ever since i could read i've read the
bible
virtually every day of my life but i'd
never read the bible
start to finish and there were some
books that even
when i was a religion major at
university
i would get to some of the books and go
i i can't stay awake
for this book i just got to move on but
when you really
go through it and you see the the old
testament
as this this incredible saga
of a people trying to find the rules
that that kept them together as a people
and it felt if you disobey these rules
then it's going to end badly for us all
and the greatest the greatest
violation is to erect altars to other
gods
right let's worship false idols yeah
that's the worst one
and then along comes jesus who is
completely steeped
in all that old testament i mean he is
he is
profound in his knowledge of it and he
lives and does and says these things
but it's not like it's a philosophy it's
a narrative
a narrative which i've studied a great
deal and i believe
is is largely historical or i should say
significantly historical
i believe these things did happen and
then you have
saint paul who's trying to make sense
of what happened and and
and it's mind-blowing to me it's
mind-blowing to
to read it as a whole and put it into
perspective in that
having having spent my life in what's
mind-blowing about it
in in part i mean and i try to speak of
the bible
not from the perspective of a committed
believer and
i have my reasons for that um i guess
it's partly because i want to
concentrate on
what everyone can come to see as true i
suppose
perhaps that's it um but
it is remarkable that the bible does
in fact make a coherent narrative
because we don't understand that
it was seek it was written by a very
diverse range of people
over a span of time that we can perhaps
not even imagine
it's very difficult to tell how old this
the oldest stories
in genesis particular are the the the
the story of the fall and of adam and
eve
and cain and abel they bear all the
hallmarks of
a previous oral tradition that
would have existed in a relatively
unchanged form
for tens of thousands of years and
perhaps even longer than that and so
they're unbelievably ancient and then
parts of it obviously are newer and the
written parts are obviously newer than
any
tentative oral tradition but you have a
you have at the bare minimum
an unbelievably deep psychological
document
that weaves itself over centuries into a
coherent story and
northrop frye i would say he's a
canadian literary critic has
did more for me than any other
particular thinker
to help me understand the nature of the
narrative because fr fry
i suppose he did the same thing or i'm
doing the same thing that he did because
he preceded me
also at the university of toronto um
he assessed the bible as a work of
literature
as a narrative and that to me was never
any denigration because narrative
a powerful narrative and you talk about
this when you talk about braveheart for
example because
there isn't that much known about
william wallace historically but you
craft
you crafted a narrative that's that was
true enough
let's say to be unbelievably attractive
to people and to motivate
them very deeply because it's an
affecting movie well and if it wasn't it
wouldn't have been so popular
um and so there's a there's a truth in
narrative that i think is even deeper
than historical truth
a true like a truly profound narrative
truth is like the average of a whole
variety of historical truths
and so it's the essence of historical
truth
so it's even more true than his than
what we would consider
say eyewitness history because
eyewitness history is just
it's one battle you know and and there's
maybe an epic theme in that battle but
then imagine that you could look at a
thousand battles and you could
and you could extract out from that what
was canonical about heroic
victory across all 1000 battles you see
something like that happening in the old
testament and the narrative
the narrative thread is really quite
deep
their societies emerge
formulate fall off the path
worship false idols collapse and then
the same thing happens again and the
collapse happens and the collapse
happens because people
become too prideful the kings in
particular they don't listen to the
voice of conscience they
and a prophetic voice arises and says
you're
wandering off the tried and true path
and
you're going to be punished terribly for
that and
generally speaking the kings ignore that
and
catastrophe breaks free and you see
and in the old testament in particular
there's the promise of
the ultimate state in some sense there's
utopian promises that run through it the
search for the promised land and
then so strangely you see that
transformed into something that's not
really political in the new testament
you see that the promised land becomes
the nature of experience as a
consequence of a particular
form of moral being and and
then perhaps that has political
implications because people who acted
like that would produce a particular
state but it's no longer
it's it's no longer the dream of
establishing the state
that will solve all problems it's
psychologized and it's
it's unbelievably profound and it it's
and that's i think you can derive all of
that from from the biblical writings
without even starting to move on to
classically religious territory
and and it's and then that does beg the
question of course is what does all that
wisdom point to in the final analysis
and that's when the questions start to
become religious yes
and it will jordan it that's that's the
part to me that
um it takes it into a whole whole
different realm as you
as you say um there's a quote
from mary oliver that a friend shared
with me recently
it's uh keep some room in your heart for
the unimaginable
and i find that
in in a great story in any or any great
piece of art
uh that surprise is the central currency
of its power
there's an element of if you will of
revelation
if you will and i i think it was paul
tillich i'm not
sure who said that religion is
man's way to god and is always erroneous
but revelation
is god's way to man maybe it's carl bart
it's god's way to man and it's always
perfect
well there's there's a revelatory aspect
to any great story when you're telling
someone a story
and they didn't see coming what just
happened
that's what makes them awake that's what
stabs them broad awake
in braveheart so many people said to me
it was
it was when the woman that william
wallace loves
when her throat is cut that's when
suddenly they knew they were not
in a typical action movie um even to
the very end of of braveheart
um there would have been many people in
hollywood and were
who thought well that this movie needs
to end
with his friends swinging in on vines
and saving him we
we can't end a an expensive
historical epic movie with a guy
beheaded and
disemboweled but that was where it had
to end
for me but but how we get there
and what it says surprised me
and surprised the audience too and in
that i would think is how it becomes
resonant i was uh doing um
a charity screening of braveheart a few
years ago
for the first time in oh two decades
to sit in a theater and actually see
the movie screened not on television but
projected in a a theater and doing it
for a charity
in austin texas and at the end of the
movie
i walked up onto the stage to do a q a
and the first person who stood up was a
young woman in the front row
19 years old she so she wasn't born
when braveheart had come out and
i was surprised that she stood up first
and she said
mr wallace i don't have a question i
just want to tell you something
my fiancee died six months ago
and before he died he told me he wanted
me to watch braveheart so
i would understand the way he loved me
and i did i
i had to stop i i couldn't go on for
several minutes
it it shocked me it moved me
it surprised me um you said that you
write love stories and i guess she put
her finger on that hey
really profoundly and and the and the
idea that
that men want to be
courageous they want to be willing to
sacrifice themselves for what's worth
sacrificing for and women want a man
like that
and they women want to and they they
want to be participants in that story
in in that same journey for themselves
um and and to me it's narrative can give
you that
more than any abstract
explanation of it um i mean i i don't
mean to
there's a lot to unpack in that i i want
to go back to your
your discussion of surprise i mean
among people who assess information
theory there's a strong
association between something that's
informative and something that's
surprising
if you can predict it technically
speaking it doesn't contain any
information
and so information always comes in the
form of surprise
technically speaking and and we are
wired to
attend to what's informative because
that's what updates and teaches us
and so then you
you said revelation comes in the form of
surprise and i would say that's
virtually the case by definition
isn't it because imagine that you're
viewing this narrative through a
particular lens
you're you're in a you're in a cognitive
perceptual structure a frame of
reference
that you're using to track all the
actions and to make sense of them
and to make predictions and if something
unexpected happens that means that
you've just learned that that frame of
reference is no longer applicable to the
current circumstance and so what that
really does mean is that
something transcendent at least from the
perspective of that current frame of
reference
has in fact occurred because so that's a
mini miracle
in some sense right because
a miracle is something that doesn't obey
the laws that you're currently following
that that that that's one way of
thinking about it and so
a rebel a surprising revelation is a
mini miracle and maybe it's
because of that it's it it's what it's
reminiscent of
the fact of the miraculous generally
speaking
but i would also say your the narrative
does something else if it's profound too
it doesn't just surprise you
it also it also
gives you a new frame of reference
instantly
within which that surprise now makes
sense and if it doesn't then you're left
unsatisfied by the movie you think oh
because i've seen that often in
particularly in movies it doesn't seem
to happen quite so much in novels
where the director and the writer will
throw a
whole variety of things up in the air
and you have
it's really compelling and then about
three quarters of the way through the
movie you think
it'll be really something if all of that
gets tied together
and then it doesn't right it falls flat
it doesn't it doesn't end in a manner
that
that's that that does justice to what's
been set up
so yeah and you know that's
that's that's a classic narrative
structure right there's there's a stable
state to begin with and then something
that disrupts it
and throws everything into a state of
chaos temporarily and then
the establishment of a new state and and
a good story definitely does that for us
and guides us through that and
and shows us that we're the thing that
does that as well
well like if you take an agatha christie
movie
or or story there'll be
all of these clues and then then
hercule perot or we we have a term in
screenwriting we call it irving the
explainer
will show up at the end of the movie to
to explain everything and then it all
fits
in and the sherlock holmes movies will
often be that way too
to me they become much less fun
then the fun is is when you don't
yet know the answers but once it's
explained it's no
it no longer has any magic for me an
example would be
when i was in college and i was
a singer-songwriter and i worked with a
friend who was a magician
and we would entertain at different
gatherings and um
he was great at slighted sleight of hand
with cards he could do a
trick right in front of your face with
cards and you'd be gobsmacked
and and he would show me how he was
doing it
and all of a sudden i'd go oh gee that's
just
um it's so simple and how could i miss
that
and then he would do the same trick to
someone else
and i would be watching the trick and i
would think oh he blew it he
he he slipped he showed them they can
see how it's done
and they were gobsmacked they didn't
understand how it was done so
they were amazed but that to me
is a difference about a story like you
say the agatha
christie or or they throw up a whole
bunch of parts and they
they never come together for a great
story it's one
that you're left um
it's it's vibrating in you and you can't
fully
explain it you you just know what
happened uh i
hate to keep referencing braveheart but
but
i wanted to make a movie and it was my
first movie i i wanted to
to make a movie that would
have people walk out of the theaters the
way i walked out of theaters at
different times in my life and would say
my life will never be the same after
what i just
experienced there i mean that that's
always been what i was
look for and that happened with
braveheart i had a
huge tough scott
i mean a burly brawling head-butting
scott
come up to me after screaming a
braveheart and look at me with tears in
his eyes and say
i will never forget that not ever and
and i think of like a story like tolstoy
wrote a tale called the wood felling
or the wood-felling party and it was
about
some some russian soldiers who were
fighting
i believe they were fighting afghan or
you know muslim
troops in azerbaijan or in the mountains
but
they they've been in this cold
forbidding place for a long long time
they've seen all sorts of death and
they've gone
out to to cut wood and
load it firewood and load it into a
wagon and a sniper
hits one of them in the leg and he's or
hits him in the body and he's bleeding
to death
and he knows he's dying and they load
him on the wood wagon to carry him back
while he's still alive but he grabs the
lieutenant by the collar and says
there are letters from my wife in my
boot
take them and send them back to my wife
so she'll have them and the officer says
yeah yeah i will but
the dying man knows he want because he's
seen
many men die and just pitched into
shallow graves and
there's just so much death so he says no
take them while i'm still alive and then
i know you'll do it
so the officer gives the order and they
strip off the man's
boot and cut through his his pant and
unwrap the wrappings around his leg that
he's done to keep warm
and there are the letters but what the
officer
sees for the first time in months and
months maybe years
is the bare flesh of a man's
leg this white sunless flesh
and it's that that reminds him that this
is a human being
and tolstoy says he was struck with a
terrible dread of the loss of life
it and and i thought even i remember i
was
18 when i read that that this is what an
artist does
you you hold up to us when we've become
enured immune to the
to certain things like you watching
women it's one time it's mini skirts
another time it's no bras
another time it's bare midriffs another
time it's something else
but you get used to something so nothing
nothing it makes you notice and the
artist looks for well what can i do that
will
make people notice to say look here see
what you see what's there rather than
what you remember
yes so there's that interplay with okay
there's there is
your perception in what you're looking
at
what you expect like the magic trick if
you're expecting one thing and you don't
see it or
or now you know the trick so now you
perceive
that's one part of it the other part of
it is
okay now i have experienced perceived
something
how do i make sense of that i mean
another thing that i've been doing is
working on the story for the
resurrection which i've studied
since well since i was in school the the
resurrection
has fascinated me more than anything
else in part because is
i think it's nt right would say
if you if you don't think the
resurrection is preposterous
you're missing the point the the whole
point
is that this is beyond anything you
could imagine
you said in a a few weeks ago i was
listening to your podcast and i was
believe this with that brilliant um
i think it's canadian who makes the
icons jonathan pagio
oh and mind-blowing yeah that was quite
the conversation
yes and and and jonathan said
um that that there's this
outside of what what we can imagine
that that is going on and you said yes
you would have
you would never you would never make
this up
um if you you make a make up this jesus
story i even believe that
well that's part of the problem with
marx's theory
that religion is the opiate of the
masses it's like okay fair enough i get
it
and and and it's actually a reasonably
intelligent critique you could say well
if you wanted to enslave people and and
oppress them
then you could invent a story and you
could use that as a manipulative
technique but then you you'd see it
seems to me that you'd want a story that
was sort of maximally fantasy-like and
attractive and so
then you're stuck with well why invent
hell
for example and then you can say
well that's where you put your enemies
you know so that's kind of convenient
but
if you take medieval experience
seriously
it's quite obvious um there's a
philosopher
in in canada taylor who wrote a
wrote about this in a book called
sources of the self
um medieval people took the idea of hell
extremely seriously and tortured
themselves with it
believe that the fruits of immorality
were
infinitely terrible and well that isn't
something that
that you that you that you use as a
childish defense against the world
in fact fear of hell is actually more
intense i would say in some sense than
fear of death
and i believe that i i think there are
things that are if you if the thing
you're most afraid of is death you
haven't been very afraid
because there are things that are far
more terrifying than death and certainly
well hell is among those uh and i
suppose that's the place that
you're eternally tortured for for your
own immorality
maybe perhaps even defined by your own
conscience anyways you wouldn't invent
that
as something attractive to the masses
and and
there's much of of religious thinking
that's like that it
it doesn't have the aspect of
there's too much burden in it for it to
be pure escapist fantasy
and there's too much and there's too
much about it that's
incomprehensible for it to be like
what would a cons a conspiratorial
machination
no it doesn't it's not a hypothesis that
that fits the data well at all
right well it's a limit case also in
some sense like you talked earlier about
you said something about sacrifice you
know and that
well people don't take the idea of
sacrifice very seriously
i i've looked at the development of the
idea of sacrifice in the old testament
and
one of the things i've come to realize
is that
one of the great human discoveries was
actually that of sacrifice because it
was the discovery of
the fact that you could modify the
present so the future was different
so it it signals the discovery of the
future by humanity
the idea of sacrifice because you become
consciously aware
perhaps after acting it out for god only
knows how long that
you can give up something that you're
deeply committed to in the present
something of extreme value
and obtain something of even more value
in the future
yeah and that's that's the discovery of
an entire dimension the temporal
dimension it's
it's it's a cataclysmic discovery it's
on the same order as
the emergence of self-consciousness and
so and then the i
and then mysteries emerge out of that so
while some sacrifices work better than
others
well why well the reaction of being to
sacrifice
seems to be reflective of the nature of
being and
that's that that's definitely the case
some sacrifices work and some don't just
like some games are playable and some
aren't
and and so sacrifice has value well then
the question starts to become
well what's of the highest value that
you should sacrifice for and what is the
ultimate sacrifice
and while you can give up something that
you own you can give up something that
you love
you can die for something or you can
sacrifice your entire life to it
and it seems to me that in some sense
the latter the last of those
is the ultimate sacrifice to
to give up your entire life for the sake
of
the highest ideal and that is the idea
of humanity and then
that is the ideal of humanity and that
is what everyone admires and that's what
we all look for in stories
that's what compels us you said well
it's the attract it's the basis of
romantic attraction and i
believe that to be the case that
associated with generosity
right to share the fruits of your
sacrifice and the question arises well
what is the ultimate sacrifice and what
would be the consequences of that
and that's obviously what's being
investigated let's say
in our religious thinking in in the new
testament there's no doubt
that that's that's what's being
investigated is there a cosmic
significance to the idea of sacrifice
in in and i i agree with that completely
and i believe that that's that that's
what is at play
when you're making the sacrifice there's
this other element
of of faith in it
the person making the sacrifice
is instead of it just being a
negotiation
central to the sacrifice it seems to me
is is a transforming
commitment that the person is being
transformed
and and what he is giving is
transforming it's like one of the
most commonly quoted lines from
braveheart is every man dies not every
man really lives
um and i didn't um
by the way it's pet peeve of mine the uh
the other another line from braveheart
besides just the scream of freedom
uh that that people do that comes from
the film
but is uh they may take our lives but
they'll never take our freedom
and that quote is on the wall of the
united states air force academy
but under it is the name william wallace
although william wallace never said that
and i keep wanting to write the english
department there and say hey listen guys
but uh the but the where that quote came
from
was me thinking okay is it ego
is it pride is it stubbornness
that keeps william wallace in the
dungeon refusing to
to submit to the king refusing to ask
the king for mercy
and maybe buy time in his life so he can
survive a while longer
and the queen the future queen comes to
him with that offer
and then she says you'll die it'll be
terrible
after he has said if i submit to him
if i cry out for mercy then everything
that is me
is dead already and she says she'll die
it'll be awful and i was thinking
well what can he answer to that
and that was every man dies not every
man really lives
and and it it became that and it in
thinking of say jesus
at golgotha that if you took a snapshot
at golgotha on the day jesus was
crucified and you said
who's the victor in this picture you
probably wouldn't be inclined to say the
guy on the middle cross
but you might if you stared at the
picture long enough
you you actually might see it human
beings may recognize
that that this one
here in this way was doing something
um beyond all understanding
and to me writing a story isn't just
me going what will surprise the audience
it's i am being surprised by the story
because it's coming through to me the
the most notable part of that in
braveheart was
uh i reached the end of the story and
and
i can see this clearly now
although it was more than 25 years ago
the
the axe is falling toward william
wallace's throat
and i wrote that on the page and then i
thought well
we can't see the ax
contact his throat and sever his head
what do we see now and then i thought
well
what about to look at this from the
point of view of him when he knows
he has fractions of a second to live
what would he look for
where would he turn his eyes would he
look at the acts what would he do
and he would know that his friends were
there so
i wrote in the last instant of his life
william wallace turns his eyes to his
friends who were stephen and hamish
and i did not know jordan until that
instant
that there between them was her
the wife he had lost and i wept
and i had no sense that
anybody else was going to relate to that
story i have a
friend named jack bernstein who's a
comedy writer he wrote ace ventura the
original
ace ventura and and and jack is
different from me
in almost every way if you put our
traits on paper words polar opposites
and he's the one i i always take my
first drafts to
and say i know this is a mess but is
there anything here
and he read braveheart and we sat down
to have breakfast and
and for him to give me his notes and he
said this is the best thing of yours
i've ever read
and and i was completely blindsided
i had had no sense that anybody would
like it that
particularly him that it had any value
but the story surprised me
and i think therefore that
revelatory quality was love i think it
happens in music
what what makes music magical is not
that it's what we
if it's just the same beat the same
monotony the same chord changes we've
heard the same lyrics we've heard
it it doesn't open us up at all
but when it's a when it's just enough
different
that we notice the difference and are
drawn into it now if it's too different
you know a when i was in school and took
music classes and they're
telling us about a tonal this and that
and abstracts it
it had no life no heart at all but when
i listen to beethoven
i can just feel the
feel the swelling of his heart
and um in in here hundreds of years
later
yes well you hear something great and
you follow it and then
there's a move of genius and out of that
greatness comes something that's even
greater
and you're so you're so satisfied by
that because you can see what's greater
emerge from what's great but you can
also see that that's characteristic of
humanity you're participating in that
yes emergence of what's better in this
surprising manner
yeah one of your new rules is um
uh is to take a room and make it
beautiful
and i love that i love that rule
i mean that that it seems so
simple um but it it
that is one of the richest ones for me i
i had that's my favorite chapter
of all the of all of both books i would
say i'm happiest with that one
wow yeah well i i had an incident um
a few years ago and i got an infection
mrsa and i was misdiagnosed and
um a doctor a friend um
and and my doctor gave me two medicines
which actually
caused it to inflame even more and um
and a week later i was at the mayo
clinic and they were discussing
amputation of my right hand
you write about that in in this book yes
yes living the braveheart life this is
an autobiography or partly an
autobiography
yes and i was i was trying to make sense
of of that experience for me and one way
i did
was to say i don't want to just
like have a hand and do hand exercises i
want to celebrate having
hands and i decided i would learn to
play the piano
i mean learn to really play the piano
and i went out and
and made a kind of sacrifice and kind of
a crazy thing i bought
a fabulous piano way
way beyond anything i deserve or my
playing merits
but having that instrument i did that
with a suit
when i went on tour i i spent like eight
thousand dollars on a suit
and it was more money than i'd ever
spent on a car like you know
i was just it was horrified by it but i
thought well i'm going to put everything
i have into this and yeah
start with this and did you find that it
was well worth it
definitely worth it no doubt about it
and and
kind of goes with uh with one of your
very first rules about
you know walk with your shoulders back
and your chest out and it's like you you
when you
when you dress well you're a different
person
well i felt i owed it to my audience it
was like if they were going to come and
see me i was going to do everything i
possibly could to
set the stage properly yes and and
you know it's all those little gestures
matter well they're not just little
gestures
right so it's there that was a that was
a mark of faith in some sense it
it certainly violated my sense of fiscal
propriety
right you know and i i i wasn't sure how
i could justify it i guess partly the
justification
would be if the lectures were good
enough you know
but i i was at least moving in that
direction
and like i said i never regretted it at
all it was exactly the right thing to do
well there's money to do it for yourself
it's i think it's
easier to do it for a loved one than for
yourself
and it it it it calls to mind the
the new testament incident of the woman
breaking the
the the box of ointments and
and anointing jesus's feet to say
um this will be remembered always and
you always have the poor and you can
always help the poor but this is
something that will last
and i thought about it that's a very
strange story that one isn't it
it's one you think would have been
edited out long ago yes
absolutely if the the
uh editors would have said no no maybe
this is not not one we should
have but um when i was in germany i was
in germany
the first time um when i was about 26
and i was in a really rough time of life
i'd
lost a job i was very much lost
and i had thought i'd rather spend my
last dollars to go to europe
than to sit alone and worry so i'd
taken a trip alone to europe and i went
to see norshchwanstein
in december the castle that
mad king king ludwig ii had built in
bavaria
and what i learned there was that
uh it had nothing to do with the
architecture of the day
the the the trends the principles of
of of sensible building it was kind of a
crazy indulgence based on his love of
opera
and and of grand romantic
gestures and it nearly bankrupted the
treasury to do it
but almost from day one it became a huge
financial success
well that's one of the things that's so
stunning about europe
is that
there isn't anything that's more
valuable than beauty
yes and i mean i mean that from the
cold-hearted
conservative um capitalist perspective
it's stunning how valuable beauty is
like the most valuable artifacts in the
world are paintings
i know ex you know accepting things like
chips to make or factories to make chips
but
single artifacts paintings are worth 150
million dollars at the
at the upper end and ancient manuscripts
that
that that are that are works of of
timeless art
and it looks like an investment in
beauty is one that pays off
as long as the thing remains in
existence
i mean i don't know how much everything
in europe that's beautiful
cost but it was plenty but
it's paid back in spades and is only
going to become
increasingly more valuable as the past
becomes more and more scarce
which is happening very very rapidly yes
so i mean these countries have more
tourists than people
yes and it's all a consequence of art
and beauty
well in rome there are something like
150 cathedrals if you
if you went to or it's enough that if
you went to
three or four a day in a month you
couldn't visit them all
and and everyone you walk in takes you
to a different place which is exactly
as they they were intended to do i
thought
your your podcast with juliet uh folger
program yeah ogre was fascinating
to have the interplay between the
writing
and and the the
well the depth of the thought that
then connected with turn this into
an actual visual visual image
i mean that's hard it's hard for me when
i've written a character
to accept a human actor
as being that character they say that um
david lean when he was directing dr
zhivago
didn't want to stay in the same hotel
as some of his actors because he like
julie christie was his lara and dr
zhivago
he didn't want to see her with a martini
in her hand smoking a cigarette
he he wanted to to direct the movie
seeing her as this pristine
object of love this this woman this
subject of love
and um and i think it's hard for
i i was fascinated to hear the process
of the way you work together to create
those images and i thought the images
were stunning and
really resonant for you know when you're
reading it you look forward to seeing
the next illustration to
to tee you up for the for the next
chapter as you
you see it and then as you're reading
you're starting to understand the image
more
and that that's incredibly rich yeah
well i was hoping and i think it
happened that that adds another
dimension
you know you have the explicit rules
let's say
that's the explicit philosophy and then
you have the implicit philosophy which
is the story
but then you have something that's even
more implicit which is the image
and the the story is richer than the
explicit rule and the image
is richer than the story but the image
isn't as clear and neither is the story
right so
you you move from focused clarity but
a rather narrow representation to what's
extremely broad and all-encompassing and
you lose something when you move in
either direction right but having all of
it
at the same time well it gives you the
advantages of all three kinds of
representation
yes and that's that that to me leads us
back to the
to the power and the resonance of art
that that any piece a painting
a piece of music a movie a story
resonates through through all of it i
when i when i was a child my um
my father was extremely frugal
but he loved music and he got i guess he
got a deal
on one of the first stereo sets it was a
huge thing
speakers were separated and had a
turntable and
he bought a collection of classical
records because they were basically
giving it away
nobody wanted it in memphis tennessee
and
and he brought those records home and in
one one side of one lp was the 1812
overture
and i would turn that on and turn the
volume up as loud
until my mother would scream at me and
and just be caught up in that i could
see the battle
i could see the armies moving i could
feel the winter i could
um you know here's napoleon's coming and
and the the cannons are going and the
the russians are fighting back and um
and it it had dimensions beyond
the simple things of of of notes
and and what was audible and i think
that that's
that that's a big part of the uniqueness
of your work there's one thing and
i'm sorry if this sounds like a fan club
but but
when i heard you speaking in the last
several podcasts and and read the
the the preface of your your new book
and to to look at all you've been
through
um all you've been through lately it
it really spoke to me about
what is required if you're gonna go do
something different
if you're gonna bring in maybe if you
just
kept your mouth shut about anything
outside of
your own area of course you were you
know in toronto you were
you were speaking about it what it
didn't feel like it was outside your
your own area to say wait a second uh
you're asking me to to violate
some things that i think are to are
violations
um you could have just been a good boy
and sat in your seat
um i could have been a good boy and
and tried to write um an
action-adventure movie
set in the present day and not write
something crazy like
something about somebody that was was
beheaded and disemboweled 700 years ago
or this upcoming movie about the pope
yeah it's going to set some people's
hair on fire no doubt and i
i you know there's a part of me well i
hope it's it's important enough to do
that
but you're you're combining you're
saying it
everything's relevant that what
these philosophers were talking about
what
these artists were painting what these
musicians are doing
what filmmakers are doing
this is all something that's
is trying to get us that way no that's
what the cathedral represents
you know it's it's it's it's an
expression in stone of this yearning to
to bring the material world into harmony
with the spirit
it's something like that and that's what
music does as well
and there's this this proclivity within
us to strive upward
and the cathedral i mean the cathedrals
they're absolutely amazing
these lattice-like structures of stone
there's something about the harmonious
interplay of shadow and light that's key
to it as well it's it's like the opening
up of dark matter to
the light that pours in that's all
embodied in the architecture
and and and i i i can't say and neither
can anyone else what that ultimately
represents and then to bring
music into that space and and tradition
it's all pointing upward to something to
to the direction that we're supposed to
go it's
it's so terrible to see these buildings
empty out
i mean thank god that they're being
preserved in some sense by the tourists
who come there driven by a sense of
awe but we we can't inhabit them anymore
the way that we used to and that's a
that's a terrible thing it means there's
a kind of ideal
that we that we're no longer we're no
longer pursuing
perhaps we're no longer pursuing it it
seems like a catastrophe to me
no one really knows how to revitalize it
though unfortunately
so well the i think one of the problems
to me when
when i was in paris working on men in
the iron mask
i would want on a sunday morning to to
go to a mass and it was very difficult
to find
[Music]
well for one thing in a baptist we would
church would start at 11 o'clock on a
sunday morning and the masses aren't
like that but go into say the cathedral
saint-germain and
there was no one there it was uh it's
magnificent
ancient cathedral and and you know a few
tourists and
the place the place didn't feel dead the
architecture was alive
but but it it was very difficult to have
a congregation
and a congregation is what the church
of course is supposed to be it's it's
a collection of people who are united
and
and indifferent it's you know it's a
collection of sinners
um acknowledging their sins and
i i think that that is a fascinating
thing to me about
how we keep um
well it's so surprising it's also so
surprising
that those hundreds of years ago when
those buildings most of those buildings
were built that
those cultures would dedicate themselves
to such great cost to produce these
absolutely spectacular impossible
buildings made out of stone or brick
these these these they're like a dance
in stone
they're so magnificent and then to fill
them with with
the greatest of artworks and and
to to to bring the light in in the most
colorful possible ways
and then to bring the music in to set
the scene
and then to have everyone come in and
commit
to at least not being as bad as they
were
right like it was a joint moral
enterprise that everyone was involved in
you can be as cynical about that as you
want and and talk about you know sunday
christians and all of that but
an hour a week to contemplate how it is
that you should be living your life
or to become in tune with your
conscience once again which
at least the confession can offer that
um
and and and then to see that so much
effort was poured into that
it's amazing that that over occurred and
and then it's also equally amazing that
we've stopped doing it because you might
think well
wouldn't wouldn't we be interested in
jointly coming together and saying well
here's how we're inadequate and
here's how we're conceptualizing what
would be ideal and
couldn't we move together toward that
and i was talking to bishop baron
this week and about this issue about
the the loss especially in the catholic
church of young people and
it seems that there's a great adventure
there
that isn't being communicated properly
and and and it's a terrible loss
for all of us what do we have to replace
that
you know i've talked to the new atheists
especially sam harris
and it's not like i don't understand
their arguments it's not like i don't
have sympathy for them for that matter
but
there's nothing poetic or artistic or
magnificent
about
the alternative yes right it loses it
loses
it loses there's something that just
disappears
it's the it's that artistic ineff
ability there's no room
there's no obvious room for that in the
say the enlightenment world view
i i'm an admirer of stephen pinker for
example
um and he falls into the enlightenment
rationalist camp
um and in his book the language instinct
he talks a little bit at the end about
culture philosophy music art and all of
that religion even for that matter to
some degree but it's like a throwaway
chapter at the end
whereas by my way of looking that's the
whole book
all of that that artistic endeavor and
that shades into the religious endeavor
and that that's the scent that's not
some side effect of human cognitive
development
quite the contrary it's the central
feature
and i agree with jordan when when you're
speaking with julia
the the most recent uh podcast i heard
the uh it reminded me her
her description of her life reminded me
of uh
an experience i had in russia i was in
saint petersburg and we were doing a
a scout um for a film i wrote called
love and honor based on
a novel that i wrote and and we were
finished with the scout we had seen
everything that
that we were scheduled to see and this
young woman who was in her early 30s a
russian woman
asked if there was anything else we'd
like to see because we had some time and
i said well
i'd love to see some of your churches
and she got
this quizzical look on her face she was
surprised that and a hollywood director
would ask that
and she said well i'll take you to my
church
and i said you've got a church and she
said oh yes i'm christian
and i said but you grew up when that was
discouraged even almost illegal
or your parents christian and she said
no um
their mother's a confirmed atheist or
her father was baptized as a child but
he's also an atheist
and so i said well how did you become
christian
and she said there was no beauty
i was a young girl walking around and
nothing was beautiful
and one day i passed the church and i
could see candlelight in it and
heard music coming out and i went in and
i kept going
and i kept going and i became a
christian
and and and that to me says
so much um and people have no idea they
have no idea
that's why i wrote chapter eight they
have no idea how much they're starving
for beauty
yes like it's it's a hunger that goes
far beyond
well let's not say that it doesn't have
to go beyond material hunger but
it it
no matter how well fed you are without
some relationship to beauty
there's too much suffering in the world
for it to be viable it's the ant it's
along with truth it's the antidote to to
suffering
it's not opt it's not uh optional
right it's crucial and you can tell that
by its economic value
for those who are hard-headed it's like
you can't point to anything with more
economic value
period the end and so
well some weeks back when you were you
were
i felt really working your way back
that that that work and engagement and
in your calling is
helping to heal and sustain you
you said something along the lines of
that
that you wondered why in the
christian community and religious
community people
were telling you that your work
means so much you know why
why it it it's it's somewhat
overwhelming
to realize that so many people are
drawing
from you and and i think i can it is
completely
it is i i today i was sitting on a bench
with my friend who walks with me and
this kid came up to me
and he said apologies for
interrupting you but i was listening to
your podcast while i was walking down
the street and i saw you here he said
and he started to tear up right away he
said five years ago i was suicidal
and i was i've been listening to your
lectures on a regular basis he said an
hour and a half a day
which seems like an overdose to me
he said he's invented prosthetic limbs
and
has helped all sorts of disabled people
and is on his way to mit
it's like just a random
meeting on the street you know yes
yes and thank god for that too much
yes of course it is but i tell you and
like i know you like to understand
you know that's the the um there's
something else you said a couple weeks
back about i
i want to i want to understand why i
want to understand
why this story makes sense and and i do
too
but the what of it all that to me gets
at the
why of it all but the what of it all is
that
you speak to people
like me and like others who
who know this this experience
of more who know who know what it is to
stand in awe
to to feel the awe of a moment
and you combine all the different
elements of
of perspective of thought of experience
and you you
validate or endorse that
that people who choose faith and who
seek courage
and sacrifice as crucial
divine values are not idiots
it's i think that that's and it's no
accident that crucial and cross are the
same thing
yes yes exactly
and and and you know we we go through
this thing of well
um you're just you're you're choosing an
opiate
and and to me it's like well um the
the alternative is not attractive too i
when
i started working on the pope story i
came across a
a statement that i believe is one of the
um talk show guys late night talk show
guys had said
conan o'brien i believe it was but he
said that
uh pope francis had made a pronouncement
that he thought even
atheists could go to heaven and in
gratitude atheists have said
um that the pope when he dies is welcome
to
enter their endless void of nothingness
so well that you know the problem with
that worldview
is in some sense that endless void of
nothingness confronts us right here and
now
yes exactly that i i try to tell people
i'm
i'm not so much concerned about life
after death as life after birth
um jesus said come that you can have
life and have it more abundantly
and and i'm not trying in a movie to
to espouse my particular dogma i don't
believe in my own dogma
my you know my own dogma is is
is limited and and i'm not i'm not
trying to think that when i was in
school
and i'd study systematic theologians and
i remember asking
my mentor who was the head of the
department um
what is really the point what what are
they trying to do
and you said well they're they're trying
to have a system
of understanding that that holds up
from every angle but well how's that
working out for them
because ultimately you get into
do you have faith or not when i write a
story
it's it's i've got to
jump in and trust and i don't know where
they'll lead
but i know that to not jump in is
is death and so for me it's like
the old testament says you know i set
before you
life and death choose life
and and that to me is what i
i hope my work's about and i'm damn sure
it's what
your work's about um i want to talk i
want to talk
about your life as well because
it's it's i'm very curious to see how
these things are managed
so you you grew up in tennessee is that
correct
yes yes and so
tell let's start there and tell me and
you worked
you worked with an animal show in in
florida
oh in in nashville so nashville in
nashville
so so yeah my father was from lizard
lick
tennessee and um um
the the men in my father's family are
alton elton
dalton lyman gleam and herman thurman
and clyde
thurman it sounds like it sounds like a
group of names from lizard lick
and by the way brilliant people
um my father's cousin um
gleeman was verner von braun's
right-hand man at the redstone arsenal
in huntsville alabama he was a genius
mechanical engineer
building the the rockets and um
his uh there wasn't a whole lot of
education the previous generation of his
family but they were brilliant men and
my mother skipped two grades in school
and dreamed of being a writer but she
didn't tell me that until i was
grown my grandmother had a country store
one room country store made of wood
that my grandfather had salvaged from
the wreck of a tennessee riverboat
and i sat in the back of that store on
the desk
i'd fashioned out of sacks of pig feed
and wrote my first story and i just
always loved to write when the other
kids would groan when the teacher would
say okay we're going to write
we're going to free write write a write
a passage write a theme
right now how did your parents respond
to that interest of yours that
interest in writing well so so my
parents
my my mother was the artist
my father loved singing but
he was extremely practical he had worked
full-time
since he's 14 years old while going to
school but he
he had full-time jobs during the
depression and
and he scraped for every dollar he was
incredibly frugal
so he it was his greatest dream that
my sister and i could get an education
which he and my mother had not
been able to get higher education though
they read everything my mother read
everything particularly
my father was a great salesman
if if you sent my father to
your enemies anywhere they'd call up and
say i'm sorry i'm going to knock it off
uh he was my father could just he loved
people but he was afraid of
me having a um an airy fairy kind of
career one that
that would be impractical and when i was
in college i started a little record
company
and i had a local hit um i
started my own record company i sold the
records i went to the stores and went to
the radio stations and
and i had an encouraging hit what kind
of equipment did you use
um i i it was just me and a guitar
but it was in the folk era and i
and i found a studio in i went to school
at duke in
in durham north carolina and there was a
studio in greensboro
uh and one in winston-salem so i'd make
the drive over there and
make a recording you know save my money
and and make a
have a three-hour session and make a
couple of of sides of a record and
and put it out and i met chris
christopherson
who is absolute genius songwriter wrote
me and bobby mcgee
and many others and he was a rhodes
scholar
and an airborne ranger and a boxer
and he was the kind of renaissance manly
man
that i aspired to be that i related to
and he came to duke for a concert and i
got to meet him backstage and i
told him how much i loved writing and
and singing and he said man you've got
to go to nashville
and he was thoroughly drunk at the time
but
i thought okay that and he didn't know
me at all
but i seized on that advice and i heard
about
a park a theme park opening up called
opryland
and they were looking for summer workers
and i went over and auditioned
and i did a a a comedy song that i'd
written as a kind of a parody of a
country song
um tammy wynette had had a hit about a
couple who spell things so their
children don't understand what's going
on and
it was called the i d-i-v-o-r-c-a i
remember that
yeah all right so yeah you're from an
area that they had country music oh yes
definitely
well so i wrote a song called me and the
d-o-g
and um and they offered me a permanent
job
as manager of animal shows and i had a
piano playing pig
uh named pigarachi and i had a duck that
played the drum and i named him bert
backquack
and i had 8 000 people a day see that
show
and and i put it together i hesitate to
ask what the pig could play
the piano he would play happy birthday
but but the way we had it worked he was
there was a sequencer
it was the early days of the moog
synthesizer
and we had a sequencer so that wherever
he hit
on the keyboard or rooted and i put a
little um sparkly bow tie on him and he
had a white
uh chest and a black uh main body and
white hooves so
he looked like he was in a tuxedo see
this is the difference this is one of
the differences between canada and the
united states
that sort of thing happens in the united
states that would never happen here
oh it was awesome it was yes
it was awesome and
well uh there's a theatrical element to
the united states that always just stuns
me
when i when i go there because it's
almost completely lacking in canada and
not to our advantage i might also add
well i tell you jordan when i went to
nashville
and i left i left duke i left i had done
one year at the seminary
i was head of the religion majors
committee i was kind of a leader
among students and and i was kind of i
hate to put it this way but i was sort
of the golden child of my parents
hopes that you know i was going to go be
a doctor a lawyer
um and right the classic game of of
parents who want education for their
children but aren't educated themselves
yes of course and and i had
actually spoken with my my the pastor of
my
home church the one i grew up in and and
he asked me if i felt the call to be a
pastor when i was majoring in religion
and i
i just studied religion because it
fascinated me
um and it seemed more relevant and
at that time i hadn't settled on
becoming
a writer and what what year were you in
university when was this what year
i graduated in 71 i was in seminary
until 72. so you were doing you were
studying religion
right at the height of the hippie era
essentially oh yeah
absolutely and did you have hippie
leanings or were you
buttoned down conservative type at that
point well
i i i would say i was more conservative
but i but school was a time for me to
to try to be open like when you talk
about the
personality traits of openness yeah well
you're very open so
well i hope i am um
well it shows you wouldn't you you
wouldn't be driven to create
that way and you wouldn't have attained
this level of success across these
multiple disciplines and
in the diverse range of your activities
that's all
emblematic of of high high levels of
trade openness
right so multiple interests interest in
philosophy interest in fiction
interest in art the capacity for
aesthetic experience
all of that is deeply biologically
rooted all of that it's a real
it's a really fundamental trait
the reason i i i wonder
about uh the the various interplays of
my traits is that
at that time i was also considering
going into the marine corps
and being a platoon leader in vietnam
which is the
are you an orderly person yes oh yes
okay
and and a hard worker you said that
right at the beginning so you're very
high in conscientiousness
that's orderliness and industriousness
and very high in openness and that makes
you a complex
personality because openness tilts
people towards liberalism and radicalism
but conscientiousness tilts them towards
traditionalism and
and conservatism and so you have to
marry those two
opposites right rare combination of
traits
like the extreme levels in any traits
are rare but if you take the extremes of
two traits and bring them together
that's particularly rare
and yes and conscientiousness and
openness fight to some degree because
if you're creative you like to break
things but if you're orderly you don't
really like the mess
yes absolutely and in fact jordan i i
think that that's that that conflict
within me has been the source of of a
lot of distress
um and depression i felt
i i started to get depressed when i was
in nashville
and part of it was that i i felt very
alone i didn't have many peers i didn't
have
people with whom i could that i shared
musical
interests with i that i could have a
conversation about
kierkegaard might i have a i have three
sons and my youngest is named sauron
after kierkegaard um
nobody that i was around had any idea
what soarin meant or was or although i
hadn't named him that then
but when i went to nashville
i knew that i was i was flying in the
face of what my
parents had sacrificed mightily for me
to have
and it was really distressing for me and
i
i made a vow that two things wouldn't
hold me back a lack of effort or a fear
of failure
so i would plunge in and wherever i had
an opportunity i would
do the best i could i was working 60
70 hours a week at the animal show
at the theme park but i got up every
morning at 4
30 and would write a song every day
okay so that's okay so that's the the
first thing i'd like to highlight
because i am interested in what's made
you successful across these multiple
domains and
part of it is while the fortune that the
marriage of openness and
conscientiousness
there's a paradox there but that
that capacity for dedicated work and
discipline conjoined with creativity
that can make both of them move very
very rapidly
yeah well like i got signed
to nashville's biggest music publisher
and
they considered me really prolific
ideas a song a day that's and did you
decide you were going to do that you're
going to get up at 4 30 in the morning
you're going to write a song
so how did you because are you waiting
around for inspiration or you just write
the damn
song right i if i dragged my butt out of
bed at 4 30 in the morning i was going
to write a damn song
and yes and and and i actually learned
later that that was too much but i
didn't know it then i felt i have to
you have to do too much before you
figure out how much is enough
exactly to be when you're young that's
the time to figure out
what's too much because you can actually
tolerate it
yeah you can overload yourself and then
pull back
well i was living in a one bedroom
apartment in a nice
apartment building i mean it was clean
it was safe but i had no furniture
i was sleeping on the floor i didn't
want to spend any money on furniture
and i saved my money and after about
two years i felt i wasn't getting
anywhere i wasn't having any songs
recorded you know i wasn't
i was making a little money and with
this publishing company but not much and
and i was making a pretty good salary at
the theme park
but i'd saved my money and i decided i
was not being successful because i
wasn't committed enough i had a picture
of beethoven which is a
rather iconic picture of him holding a
notepad and frowning up at the sky and
and i thought okay i'm going to be like
beethoven i'm going to commit
completely and i
i quit my job and i spent all day every
day
alone in my apartment
i almost never went out no friends no
social life at all
just writing studying practicing
all day every day and after about
four or five months of that i had a
breakdown and
i mean really like panic attacks
couldn't eat
um debilitating depression
uh you extra are you extroverted yes yes
so that would have been very hard on you
that isolation
yeah i mean i i i'm like my father i'll
i'll go into
a restaurant and i'll get to know the
busboys and
i hug everybody and kovitt's been bad on
me
but um it was
it was raining every single day there'd
been 14 straight days without
a patch of blue sky and i decided if i
don't see some blue sky
i'm going to kill myself and i loaded
everything i could carry in a
toyota and i drove to california by
myself and
got out here and kept trying to write
songs
ultimately got a job
because i was still running my own
little music company
and that impressed some people in
in the music business that i would that
that i could walk into an office without
a calling card without a company name
talked to the secretary get past the
receptionist get my songs to the
producers and they were impressed with
that and and
they offered me a job i was
at a at a music major music publisher
for about a year and then they had
you had you graduated from duke at that
point oh yeah yeah how old were you when
you went out to california
25. okay okay and um
and then um and why california apart
from the sun
i mean were you going there because it
was hollywood because it was did you go
to l.a
yeah went to l.a but they had a
they had a music scene in la that so it
was
music was either london which i didn't
have the money to go to
in new york which i thought they're
going to hate me up there i'm just i'm a
southern
christian they're they're going to hate
me and
nashville i didn't really love
country music one brilliant music
publisher listened to my songs once and
and he was so elegant and thoughtful and
he he looked at me and he said
do you love country music and i said
well i really
respect it and he went nah it's not what
i asked you
he said if you don't love it it's not
going to work here
and don't sell your soul for pennies and
i thought well
la is the only place where there
they're that the kind of music that i
seem to like
besides london is happening and i'll go
out and try it out there
and what did you like at that point who
were you listening to
guys like cat stevens um i
you know i thought he was an incredible
blend of of
surprising music and ethereal powerful
lyrics um i also love
neil diamond who to a lot of my friends
seemed real cheesy but i thought
you know the taproot manuscript oh gosh
that god that's a great album
i was thinking that was my favorite
album ever
that's that's head and shoulders above
anything else he ever made and it's
arranged so brilliantly it's got one pop
song on it
which really doesn't belong but the rest
of it is it's really quite brilliant
that
oh suleiman is just incredible
and it works very well as an album as a
totality it's great
my my wife loved that when she was a kid
grade five and i listened to it through
her and i've listened to it
you know from time to time ever since
it's brilliantly arranged too
and yes which is quite striking
absolutely that was my favorite album
ever probably
cool well lots of people who are
watching this won't have heard of that
so i would
regardless of your opinion of neil
diamond you should listen to taproot
manuscript because
yes he did a lot of things in there that
paul simon did about 20 years later
bringing in the african music and so
brilliantly
it was very creative that album oh
absolutely
and so that's so cool that that's your
favorite album
yeah that's who else you saw cat steven
so you like the
those were very melodic um
very lyric based um
who else were you listening to van
morrison um
i really loved van morrison and um
and of course i like the beatles but i
i really like the rolling stones too and
i thought they were
not underrated how could you say they
were underrated but
like if you listen to sympathy for the
devil
in the line i wrote a tank in the
general's rank when the blitzkrieg
raged and the body stank yeah that's a
killer song that
i defy anybody show me a lyricist that
writes with more power than that
yeah he was somewhere else when he wrote
that that's that's that's uh that's a
pretty
pretty dark song
but i wasn't in a band
and i um and i i wasn't
it was it felt that i was trying
to get my arms around too much that i
i didn't know how to go from sitting in
a i lived
in in los angeles i lived in an attic
over a garage it was built in
it was a it was nicely built in but i
could only
i'm six foot two i could only stand
upright in the very center of the
apartment because the roof was so
slanted and
um but i had a piano and i i worked all
day
and on on songs
but i just i wasn't i wasn't having any
success then
and i met a woman who became my wife
and her father was absolutely brilliant
he had been a prisoner of war in
world war ii he was a bombardier
navigator and he was shot down
in 1942 or early 43 so he was a prisoner
of war for
a couple of years stalaglift iii
and he'd written a screenplay about his
experiences he was um
close friends with william peter blatty
they had been
they had worked exorcist yes and blatty
was also a genius and they had worked as
a
an intelligence unit counter
intelligence unit during the korean war
and they were friends and bladdy's
success with exorcists kind of
inspired my father-in-law and he'd
written a screenplay and i'd never seen
one
and when i picked it up it was on her
coffee table
and and the form
lit me up jordan because it didn't have
the
sort of pompous
uh nature of so much modern fiction
when the the writer's trying to show off
his knowledge um it
it it it had there was an essential
nature like when you talk about
how to write and all the the editing to
get down to the essence
screenplays have to do that they were
like songs and that
every word has to count and all you can
really portray effectively in a
screenplay is
what you see the character do and what
you hear the character say
so what that character is thinking has
to
come through in what which gets us back
to that
how is thought manifest in in the
concrete world
and i decided to try that and how are
you
how are you surviving at that point you
were writing music were you
were you employed by this this this the
offices that you had walked into
uh yeah i i i had a job for
a for a year and
that they paid me well
and i was extremely frugal so that
i mean i i didn't drink i didn't smoke i
didn't
i i didn't eat out you know i
i made beans and stuff and uh
so i was able to i was able to get along
and once in a while my mother would send
me a little money
and my father would call me and say
don't miss any meals
but he wanted me to not suffer but he
wanted me to
under to undergo the cost
of my choices yeah well it's really hard
when you're a parent to know
how much to help your kids you know oh
gosh
you can easily over help them yeah oh
yeah
it's a real problem oh it's a it's it's
such a hard question
um is you you want to you steal from
them if you take their problems away
right you deprive them of deprivation
yes yes and do you deprive them of the
of the of the solution that they might
come to on their own too
well i i landed a job with architectural
digest the
phone rang out of the blue one day that
i i wrote a novel
and got it published over the transom by
a publisher called gp putnam's sons
oh it's a great publisher that you must
have been thrilled oh gosh i was over
the moon and um
and my thought was i didn't have an
agent but i thought
i want if i i want to write my own novel
before i
take a class on novel writing or
you know i i don't want somebody who's
failing at something tell me how to do
it
and i want to discover
what is in me to do what is my way what
is my style of doing this
and if i write the novel then
as well as vince lombardi i believe was
the one who said it the more you
sacrifice the harder it harder it is to
surrender
if i write the novel then i will be
willing to fight my way through the
rejections that will
inevitably come to to see it through
and i went to the library and got
down a bunch of novels and and copied
the
addresses of the publishers out and had
15
new york publishers and i wrote 15
letters
and described my my new novel and asked
if they would like to see it
and the very first one was gp putnam's
sons and they said
send us the first three chapters
i did they called a week later and said
we'd like to see the rest of
it right that never happens
and uh and then i got 14 rejection
letters some of
some of which i got after the the book
was published
and uh um and along in there
i um uh i
got married and my wife got pregnant
and uh my wife got pregnant we got
pregnant
and she had mormon ancestors
uh and she knew because of them she knew
the entire genealogy of her family back
as far as it could be traced
and all i knew was that we were
tennesseans i didn't know about scott's
irish
i didn't know about any of that you know
we spoke english so i was like i guess
we're english
and but
she had said to me
i never really imagined being a mother
but if you get me pregnant
you have to promise to take me to europe
because she loved to travel
and she was a dancer and worked
made money was very successful at it and
and i was saving my money and i was
writing for architectural digest at the
time i wrote
eight or nine art articles for
architectural digest
which was interesting because i had been
living in an attic
over a garage you know
multi-million dollar homes uh and um
well you probably appreciated them more
oh yeah oh yeah in my
my my gimmick jordan was
most people who are reading this
magazine don't have the money that the
people who are living in these homes
have
but there must be some principle of
making a place
beautiful that is applicable and if i
can share that with them
and the way the the person who's
building the home both the
the architect designer and the and the
the owner um the way their personalities
what is driving their process in all
this could be interesting
to to the buyers of the magazine whoever
would read my article and
that seemed to resonate so i would make
i'd make nice money doing that
and would save it so we went to europe
and i had heard that there were wallaces
in scotland
so we were in london and i suggested a
detour to
scotland and we were walking into
edinburgh castle
and there was a statue of a man named
william wallace
and on the other side of the door
flanking the door with him was
the statue of robert the bruce and i
knew robert the bruce
from a bobby burns poem which of course
you quote the
would send you know the gifty ghias to
see ourselves as others see us in your
new book
um i knew from scots which
had with wallace bled i knew
the reference to wallace from that
robert the bruce poem about
robert the bruce so i asked a guard
there
who is this william wallace and he said
he's our greatest hero
and i'm elbowing my pregnant wife going
greatest hero hunting here that wallet's
greatest hero
and uh and i said to the blackwatch
guard there
well was he an ally of robert the bruce
and fighting
the english and the guard
said the magic words that every writer
loves to hear he said
no one will ever know for sure
uh but our legends say that robert the
bruce may have been
in on the betrayal of william wallace
to clear the way for himself to become
the king
well i didn't know that william wallace
had been betrayed
but that statement was like
hearing that judas iscariot and saint
peter
were the same person it it made me
wonder
what if there was something so powerful
and profound in
the life and death of william wallace
that it transformed robert the bruce
from a person who would betray his
country's greatest hero
into this country's greatest king and
i thought this is a mind-blowing story
but i had a pregnant wife and i had to
find a way to feed her
to feed her and my new baby and
and um and i didn't feel ready to write
that story
so we came back to los angeles and i got
a job working in television
and television is an incredible grind
it's like running into
a freight train yes it's insatiable
insatiable
and in those days and in these days like
if you're on the netflix series it might
be
10 episodes a year well in
in those days it was 22 episodes a year
and my mentor was a guy named steve
cannell and he taught me
tremendous stuff and but one thing
how did you get a job in television
uh i i had written a screenplay and a
friend of mine
i was working out at a gym and i
love to work out in fact it it keeps me
it keeps me sane and i just
i enjoy it i enjoy being in gems and and
um
and there was a guy there um who was
working out really ferociously as well
and
um he was telling another friend their
stories about elvis presley
and my father had seen elvis
when he was the truck driver and was
getting paid like 50 dollars
to sing at a supermarket opening
and i told him that story that my father
saw elvis at a supermarket opening
getting 50 bucks
and we started chatting and that guy
that i was talking with was mike post
who is the most successful television
composer probably ever absolutely
brilliant guy
and we hit it off and became friends and
and one day he said to me how are you
how are you making money you know what
do you do and i said well i'm you know i
write
screenplays and i that's that's what i'm
doing now i'm a writer and
and he said you ought to meet steve
cannell and he was doing
mike was doing the music for steve
kennel so mike made it his business to
get steve to
read one of my scripts and eventually
a sample of my writing got there
what attracted them was they were doing
a
show about a guy from texas who's
basically a well dare i say a [ __ ]
kicker
and um and i was telling them lizard
licks stories
right right now and they immediately
and you know once i told them about the
piano playing pig
they were like give this guy an
assignment
and from my first decision yeah that's
definitely a door opening story that one
yeah and so i got i and i became he
became my mentor
and we had a we had a really fabulous
relationship for about
three years and then we started to get
sideways
um in and i guess it's an old story
that you know a mentor and the mentee
the protege
you know the protege starts thinking he
knows what he's doing and the mentor
maybe you know has mixed feelings about
it and
and i realized i had to leave and
and i did and what shows did you work on
then
um well the first one i worked on was
called hunter
uh which was a long-running cop
drama um also created uh co-created with
steve by my friend frank lupo who
just passed away about a week ago and
they had done a team
and um frank and steve had done a team
so i worked on a show called hunter in
the show called j.j starbuck and
another show called uh sunny spoon none
of which became big hits but they were
all on for about a season
um and and and and i made a lot of money
doing it i mean i had a i had a
beautiful
home and german cars in the driveway and
a tennis court in the front and a
swimming pool yes you said you're a car
you said in your book that you're a car
aficionado
i'm a hillbilly jordan i just like i
just like elvis i love them
and so um yeah well they were they were
in the 60s and 70s
50s as well they were still simple
enough so that you could kind of
understand them
and have an affinity for them you know
they've got so sophisticated now and so
abstract that it's hard to
it's hard to fall in love with them
they're great car new cars are so good
but they're so good they're kind of not
interesting anymore that's right that's
right
and all my relatives could fix them and
tear them apart and
and my oldest son restores cars he'll
take a junked
like 65 mustang and a year later it
looks
brand new he's he's incredibly gifted
with that
but deeply satisfying work that yes
absolutely but um uh
when i left when i left kennel it was
terrifying in a sense because i had gone
from having no idea where my next dollar
would come from
to my salary doubling every year for
four years
and then suddenly having no idea where
my next dollar would come from
and i couldn't having been steve's
protege and then getting sideways with
him i couldn't even get
a meeting to pitch an idea at a network
and i i went to features almost in
desperation and
and has decided that i would write that
story
that um so that was still lurking in the
back of your mind
oh yeah yeah and but but there's a
watershed moment in this
um i was i've i
felt the the the dark voices
clutching at my insides you know and
screaming through my head and my
stomach was nodding up and my hands were
trembling and
i found i couldn't write and um and i
started to get really afraid then
because i'd always been able to will
myself through that was it was my
most remarkable trait was just that sort
of scottish stubbornness
no matter what the pain is i can take it
longer than you can dish it out
and um and i was finding that
i felt i was betraying my sons and i had
that's a terrible feeling though were
you you were getting depressed was that
what was
happening yes yeah that's that well the
problem with depression is that it
actually
saps that will like not only is it
painful
beyond description often but it goes
after the very thing that you would use
to fight it
yes exactly and
my sons were the same age i was when my
father had lost his job and had a
complete breakdown i mean hospitalized
and everything
and and i just i felt that
that lurking and i got on my knees
and i said a prayer and
i i mean i did i had nowhere else to go
and i got on my knees and i prayed
uh what matters most to me right now is
my sons
yep and and maybe the best thing
for them is not that they grow up in
private schools and
german cars and you know nannies and
everything maybe maybe it would be best
for them
if they lived in a house even one
without indoor plumbing
the way i lived when my father had his
breakdown
but my father also showed me how a man
gets up
and he did get up and he came back to
tremendous success
and and i thought if that's what you
want me to show my sons
then please bring it on and please help
me bear it but if i go
down in this fight i pray
i go down not on my knees to hollywood
but
standing up with my flag flying fighting
for what i believe in
and i stood up and i wrote the
screenplay for love and honor
and that got me into the office of a
young woman named rebecca
pollock who's sydney pollock's daughter
cindy [ __ ] directed
out of africa jeremiah johnson
um three days of the condor and
i told her the story of braveheart in
about 10 minutes
and she went my god go write that
and i said do you want an outline or
something and she went what i'm going to
tell you how to write act 2.
go write that and um
and that led me into what do you think
it was about you that
that made doors open
for you like that it's it's quite a
remarkable theme
i mean these are all very difficult
enterprises to gain a foothold in
and and you tell stories over and over
about people
offering you the chance was that the
salesman the salesman
skill that your father had do you think
what what was it
i i i have to guess jordan because the
to see ourselves as others see it is
clearly the hard thing
but i do think i do think i
am am incredibly
blessed that i had this salesman father
whose heart was as big as the ocean and
i had
this brilliant mother who was who was
absolute steel inside and
and tinder i mean she was she was an
iron
iron hand and a velvet glove and um
it makes sense because you think well
you need the creativity and you've got
that and you need the discipline to work
and you've got that
but that's not enough you have to be
able to market you have to be able to
make contact with people you have to be
able to communicate with them
about your material because otherwise
you languish
but you have that too yes but i i think
there's
i think there's something and look you
know whenever anyone says
oh this was it you know thank goodness i
had this gift of god
is so self-aggrandizing like you're
elevating your
your gifts but but i think there was
there is a a thing that i didn't create
but i have chosen to follow which
is there's something about being bold
and being
willing to take the punch
to to be able to walk in it's like when
i decided i would write my screenplay
first i like
i like writing original screenplays
without going to a company and saying
um like it was an original screenplay
what we call a spec screenplay
that got me into rebecca's office in the
first place that got her to listen
about braveheart and there's there's an
element of tremendous
daring to say
i i don't have to have your endorsement
or your money
to sit down and write this and in fact i
like the equation
of it to say if i write this and i've
made this choice a dozen times
in my career if i write it and it
doesn't sell
i will live with that but i will have
written
what i believe i will have written what
i want i
will have written the movie i want to
make and if you say you don't want to
buy it
the next guy might and then you're going
to look like an idiot
and that that equation that theme comes
out quite strongly in secretariat
yes yes it does because she pursues that
that investment in in her horse and that
famous remarkable horse
yes single-mindedly and and and
and at high risk yes and i
i feel that um there's something and
obviously we can be we can be
projecting this onto the horse but
the the metaphor of the movie for me was
i actually i wrote the i wrote the song
of the end credits um called it's who
you are
um it's not the prize it's not the game
it's not the score it's not the fame
when every road looks way too far it's
not what you have
it's who you are and in that
you choose your race and then you run
and and i'll i'll say that to myself
over and over i say it to myself daily
is don't miss the chance to live this
day
and when i i'm divorced and it was the
most
wrenching horrific thing of my life
and i would i would get out of bed in
the morning
and drop straight down to my knees and
pray for the strength to get through the
day
and at the end of the day when i would
get down on my knees
to say thanks i would think well
i did have faith today i did get through
the day
and at least enough to get through the
day and
and if did that catapult you into
depression as well
oh yeah oh yeah yeah no i mean it's
it sounds like it from what you're
relating and and that came through in
your book too that that
i mean you don't talk about it much but
when you touch on it it's quite clear
that that was
an experience that you know took this
the slots out from underneath you
yes and and that that uh and i don't i
don't talk about it too much because you
know there are other people involved
but you know it's my family and it was
wrenching for all of us but
it it may be that the depression also
contributed
yes you know the the
it was so highly probable it's very
difficult to live with someone who has a
predisposition to depression yeah it's
hard
and um so yeah it it
it certainly it certainly was the fight
and
within me and um uh but at the same time
there was there was something beautiful
i mean there were many beautiful things
that come out of
such darkness um one was
um i was putting up christmas lights at
the
that the house i had moved to to try to
rebuild my life and and and my sons i
would see my sons
three days a week and that was very
strained and
and and i was trying to make my home
look beautiful and i was putting up
christmas lights and i was getting
really depressed
and um i was talking with my therapist
as
a brilliant guy and and i told him about
that and
i said you know i can't really date
anybody and like
i you know i'm not seeing my sons enough
and
my neighbors don't celebrate christmas
and and i'm
i'm putting up christmas lights and i'm
getting more depressed doing it
and he said well how about this
you don't put your christmas lights up
for
your neighbors to see you don't put them
up for someone
you're dating to see you don't even put
them up for your children to see
god sees your christmas lights put your
christmas
lights up for god to see i thought god
what
what a great way to think of everything
we do in our lives
like here's here's what it is most if i
if i labor in an anonymity if nobody
knows it
um but i've done it so that god sees it
then that's better than if i did
something i don't believe in that
everybody applauded me for um
and um so that that's just been a
it's it's a choice i continually have to
make
and struggle with to affirm but
um it's it's the one i really believe in
i don't think that people would create
anything that was truly original if they
didn't think
like that you know
because if it's original and surprising
there's no track record for it
there's no proof that it's valid right
you have to there's just no option but
to take the risk and so
if that line of thinking didn't exist
then there'd be no way that you would
take the risk
exactly i mean i was always the kid that
maybe that's why creativity and
religion religious thinking are aligned
so tightly is that
you you have to make that leap of faith
to produce something that's original
virtually by definition yes and despite
you you see that again that theme sort
of playing out in secretariat because
all the advice that is given to the
chi chineri chenery is her name right
miss chenery she owns this horse
remarkable horse and
anyone sensible would have sold them
because she was going to lose everything
including her credibility
yes but she didn't
and she was right but there was no proof
of that to begin with
that was a leap of faith and i don't
i really don't see how you can do
something original without that leap of
faith
because just as i said there's no track
record
well jordan i hadn't thought of this at
all before this conversation but
but it strikes me that there's something
um as you mentioned that
in common with you and her and when i
say how isolating
it is to take that leap um
i got to know penny i i've
i've had the the opportunity to make
several movies about
people who are still living
when the movie's being made and every
time i do it i swear i won't do it again
because i'd rather
be free yes yes but
i got to know penny and boy there was
fire in that woman
and uh she was well into her 90s
when we started making secretariat and
she was
incredibly uh attractive
the her her eyes were so full of life
and were so direct
and um
when we went to the kentucky derby
together
right after the movie was made which was
certainly a magical moment you know we
just made the movie
and now we're going to it's the next
running of the kentucky derby
and and i got to go with penny and of
course
penny's in at churchill downs
she was she was a rock star and uh you
know
everybody knew we're making the movie is
uh
disney movie is going to be seen by a
lot of people and and um
we we saw the race together and
everything builds up at the kentucky
derby to the derby itself it's the derby
is like the eighth
race of eighth or ninth race of a whole
day of racing
so and then there are races after the
derby
so when the derby was over it builds
this crescendo
everybody walked back into the the party
rooms
and forgot us and i was left
out on a balcony just penny and me
and uh and we're standing there together
and i thought okay this is a sacred
moment
and um this is probably going to be the
last time i see her
and she looked down at the horse that it
just won they were they had
taken the saddle off the horse and we're
kind of cooling him down and
and she looked down and said that's
that's a well well-bred horse
um just casual comment and i looked at
her and said penny
we've come to the end of this movie
process
and and now it won't it it won't be in
the movie
uh but tell me what did you not tell me
what have you what did you want to say
that
has never been told what what have you
kept from me
and she paused and she looked down at
the the box seats
where she would sit as an owner
and she said i sat down there alone
every day alone the other owners would
tolerate me
but they never accepted me and um
and i i just thought about that there
there's there's that cost of
stepping out there of leaping out there
alone
and and the the thing to me about it
is like there's a wreck and you have to
believe it's worth doing for itself
yeah exactly and in a way
you you hope it's worth doing but you
don't
know i have i have a friend here who's a
rabbi named mordecai
finley and um you know for anybody as
gentile as me it's always fun when i say
he's my rabbi
and rabbi finley was a marine he's a
brilliant
thinker and a friend named steve
pressfield who's an
incredible writer wrote a book called
the war of art which you'd be very
interested in i think
um but steve pressfield was um
investigating his own faith he had
decided to
to to look into spiritual matters and he
asked me to go along with him to
rabbi finley's lecturers at the
university of judaism
and a rabbi finley is a very practical
guy he's
got a son in the marine corps he's got a
daughter and
israeli intelligence and and he's a
tough guy and
and he said you know people say follow
your heart instead of your head
well your heart's the only thing less
reliable than your head
so that statement sort of sat for a
minute and
somebody raised their hand and said well
then how do we know what to do
and rabbi finley paulus for a long time
as you do by the way when like like
you're considering the
the question of fresh it's not like oh
here's my pad answer it's like
well let me find what what's the true
answer right now
and he paused like that and he said
a couple of times in my life i've been
hanging by my
fingernails over the abyss
and i let go because i couldn't hang on
anymore
and i fell into the arms of god
and he said i didn't know it would be
the arms of god when i let go
if i had known it it wouldn't truly have
been letting go
and i was sitting there in this crowd of
people going
and he looked at me and pointed at me
and he goes christians know this
christians know grace
in our tradition we we have to
sort of look for that concept it's there
but we have to look for it but he said
it's grace and and i think about that
it's it's i don't know every time
when i sit down that that i'm not
wasting my time that i'm not just going
to ruin
you know a ream of paper or or or
that i'm not gonna beggar my children um
or i'm not gonna write something that
somebody's gonna
hate uh but um
but my mother had a a saying she gave me
when we had just made we were soldiers
and my father died
as written in my book about at the end
of we were soldiers my father passed
away
he died on 9 11. and uh
and we uh after
after his funeral and i was back to work
um i was calling my mother every day and
and i called her and said how are you
doing and she said well i'm
i'm doing i'm doing okay how are you
doing and i said well
i'm nervous today and she said why
and i said well um you know i've
we're testing the movie tonight we're
going to have its first
public test and she said well why does
that make you nervous
and i said well there are a lot of
people that come to these things
intentionally just to be snarky just
a just you know the sling mud at you
and and when you've put your your blood
and your sweat and your tears and your
money
into a work and you know people are
going to do that it kind of makes you
nervous
yeah and i would say so and my mother
said well honey
if they crucified jesus christ they're
going to be some people that don't like
you
so jordan if they crucified jesus christ
they're going to be some people that
don't like you
[Laughter]
you know i would like to talk to you for
another three hours
oh but i think that's a really good
place to stop i think
great and i i really enjoyed that
uh and
it was it was delightful to hear your
stories and
and to talk to you and i'm so happy that
you decided that
you'd participate in this podcast i
think people will find it
quite interesting so
i should ask you what you asked penny is
there anything
that we didn't cover that you'd like to
let people know about
you know jordany i think the the big
the big thing i'm trying to figure out
right now
and i again i i draw inspiration from
you in this that to
you know to be a teaching professor
and to to start to lecture and to start
to use
media and and and to find
and and to find an audience in different
ways
i love making movies and it's it's it's
my calling
uh but i i love music too and i
um and i'm and i'm trying to figure out
how to
to get it all out
how to both to just do it and to let
people know
it exists and i'm not sure the proper
way and
in anticipation of doing this i i made a
little website
for that new song i wrote called praise
ye the lord because i think
an affirmation right now is what we
really need to do
look at all that we have going for us
instead of
being listening to fear um so i'm trying
to figure
that notion out so um
i i'm really going to be watching you to
learn from how to do that and uh
what what the best way because there's a
part of me too that goes
i really want to be left alone i don't
want to be recognized i don't want to be
i don't want to be noticed but i also as
the bible says you don't take a candle
and put it under a
you know a table or under a bushel you
know you
try to try to show it that's
that's a very unfocused
thing to say but that's what i'm trying
to figure out uh
that between you and me personally
that's the
that's the thing i'm i'm trying to
figure out at this stage of my life is
what do i do with all the things that
i'm doing
i don't know the answer
i think it's really helpful to let
people see into your life a bit you know
people are so fascinated with what goes
on in
in hollywood what goes on with people
who are creative
to to say what it's been like to talk
about that
that's interesting and compelling and so
and and so we managed to do some of that
today
and so hooray for that and i'm looking i
tell you
i'm very much looking forward to this
new movie do you have a title for it
the swiss guard and and how about a
proposed release date any idea
it would probably be 2022
and you know i try to make the kind of
movie
that i would want to see you know that i
would want my sons to see that i want
the people that i love to see so
um it amazes me that that you and your
wife watched
secretariat and uh that thrills me
so i i hope this is a movie that would
be worthy of
your time to sit down and watch it i'm
very much looking forward to it
i hope we get to talk again me too
jordan
let's stay in touch thank you my friend
all right thank you
[Music]
still we in will trust
overfear praise
the lord
sons of rejoice
[Music]
who keeps his promises
[Music]
when we are lost
who comes and finds us
preaching the lord
when we are drowning who says
cuts the call
praise god
[Music]
my
[Music]
you